[Música]
[Aplausos]
houve um tempo muito difícil aqui no
planeta terra mundo de tempo de muita
destruição de caos de poluição um mundo
que era regido pelo lema tempo e
dinheiro
o mundo em que se contaminava as águas o
solo o ar mundo o de comando e controle
baseado na punição e na recompensa com
hierarquias muito claras
imagina difícil imaginar né mesmo
nós hoje que vivemos o mundo a conexão e
da abundância que nesse planeta já teve
uma população que viveu essa essa
trágica civilização
pois é era o tempo do ou mostrar a
pensar pensa sabe inclusive nessa época
eles trancaram as crianças em escolas e
quando a criança saiu da escola elas
continuavam estudando trancadas dentro
de casa ou em escolas de inglês
enfim enquanto a criança ficava muito
agitada muito tensa sabe que eles faziam
tavam remédios para as crianças ficarem
um pouco mais calmas ou focados
bom nesse tempo eles quando alguém
ficava doente estava perto de morrer
eles corriam e mandar as pessoas para o
hospital
nesse tempo as pessoas morriam em
hospitais sozinhos naquela frieza hua
hua
difícil imaginar né mesmo hoje que a
gente pode celebrar a morte assim como a
gente celebra quando alguém nasce e
nesse tempo obscuro
quando alguém fazer alguma coisa que
violava os princípios os valores que
causava algum dano sabe que eles faziam
levavam para o juiz que definia quem
estava certo e quem está errado e qual
seria a punição que aquela pessoa iria
sofrer e aí muitas vezes
trancavam as pessoas em presídios onde
elas ficavam se tem internada para fazer
ociosas sem ter nada para aprender e se
imagina que eles esperavam que as
pessoas mudassem de comportamento depois
dessa experiência
wii
[Música]
pois é eu tenho um sonho é movida por
esse sonho eu resolvi deixar de ser uma
aspirina no sistema pois foi assim que
eu me sinto lei há mais ou menos uns 10
anos atrás
com uma carreira super bem sucedida de
consultor organizacional psicoterapeuta
coach educadores é ter esses nomes todos
que se dão pra essas coisas e eu achava
ótimo até então quando eu comecei a
entrar em contato com algumas
tecnologias de transformação social e me
dando conta da minha insatisfação com o
que eu estava gerando porque sim quando
eu é fazer uma palestra ou uma
consultoria um coaching parece que a
pessoa ficar um pouquinho mais feliz mas
não tinha transformação de fato ali
então nesse momento inclusive muito
inspirada por uma frase da magnet mídia
que dizia assim nunca do vídeo de um
pequeno grupo de pessoas conscientes e
engajados para mudar o mundo porque foi
sempre assim que o mundo mudou quando
escutei essa frase rio ao então pode ser
que com um pequeno grupo de pessoas a
gente possa fazer alguma coisa diferente
e em muito inspirada por esse movimento
na época estudando profundamente
comunicação não violenta
dragan dreaming teoria ou todas essas
tecnologias diferentes e também no
momento de despertar espiritual muito
forte é que eu resolvi comprar uma terra
no meio da floresta tinha aqui de são
paulo e comecei a contar meus ombros
outras pessoas e rapidinho já tinha um
grupo de pessoas e de sonhadores que
também estavam muito insatisfeitos com
esse sistema que a gente chama também de
matrix e então a gente resolveu criar um
experimento social chamado pelo menos
alguns de vocês inclusive já tiveram lá
pesquisando um pouco sobre ecovilas e
comunidades intencionais pelo mundo
dom a gente foi descobrindo que algumas
delas acabavam se dissolvendo porque não
era porque o solo não era fértil e não
dava pra plantar porque não havia
sustentabilidade econômica
elas eram corrigidas pelos conflitos
ah bom nesse quesito eu estava me
preparando porque eu já estava bem ativa
dentro da pesquisa especialmente da
comunicação não violenta ótimo então
aqui está o laboratório
e a gente começou um experimento social
que tinha a ver com como é que a gente
sai da cidade e não leva à cidade junto
com a gente tem uma frase que escutei
não sei quem é o autor que falava é
fácil tirar o homem da cidade difícil
tirar a cidade do homem e esse é o
desafio que a gente vem enfrentando ao
longo desses anos né encarando um dragão
por dia porque vira e mexe quando a
gente vê a gente está reproduzido os
velhos padrões que a gente não quer mais
mas parece que a gente carrega com a
gente que está dentro das nossas células
bom e para a gente criar esse
experimento do novo mundo esse lugar
onde a gente respira não violência a
gente precisa de algumas tecnologias são
tecnologias sociais
então alguns pilares que estruturam essa
nossa nossa experiência
uma delas é a pena cultura que é uma
forma da gente se relacionar com a terra
de uma de um jeito diferente em que a
gente não usa terra mas a gente se
relaciona com ela a gente está
aprendendo pra caramba nisso a gente
precisa repensar a nossa forma de fazer
trocas como a gente lida com dinheiro é
fundamental para a gente poder fazer
essa transição luminosa gente criou uma
moeda chamada vaga lumens que inclusive
já está transbordando as nossas
fronteiras ea gente já tá trocando com
outras pessoas em outros lugares ea
ideia é que a gente possa se olhar não
mais mensurando o quanto que você
dedicou de horas para aquele projeto o
qual é a tua equipe tite
assim né o que a gente descobriu é que
quem lava prato é tão importante quanto
quem cuida das finanças ou do site ou de
um evento que está acontecendo lá
ao mesmo tempo a gente quer cuidar das
nossas necessidades de reconhecimento de
justiça então a gente vem criando os
sistemas onde a gente pode usar o
dinheiro e outras energias para que a
gente possa expressar esse
reconhecimento das pessoas
bom tem um eixo fundamental que é como é
que a gente lida com o poder já que a
gente decidiu ser uma sociedade de
centro vazio ou seja não há uma
liderança e pra mim esse tem sido o meu
principal o motivador de cura porque eu
fui a um sonhador original e comprei a
terra originalmente então aquele é um
ambiente que eu já estava muito
impregnado pelo meu poder pessoal
então o que a gente tem feito e gente
tem usado a tecnologia da social cras ia
o governança dinâmica pra gente se
organizar é que quando a gente toma uma
decisão
a gente escuta todas as vozes não há
alguém que é mais importante do que
outro então os dois princípios centrais
da sua classe a são equivalência todas
as vozes são contempladas ea eficácia
por isso a gente toma a decisão por
consentimento e não por consenso social
cras ia ela é uma evolução da democracia
porque olha só que interessante a
democracia
ela é um sistema em que sempre vai ter
um ganhador e um perdedor
mesmo que a gente tomou a decisão
baseado em maioria
então quando a gente de sol ver a esse
conceito a gente distribui poder
não dá pra falar numa nova sociedade sem
a gente olhar para a questão do poder e
curar essa ferida e que foi um dos
movimentos mais importantes que eu fiz
porque eu percebia que te poder
e dava pra mim é uma certa segurança de
que eu seria cuidada de que eu vou ser
escutada e considerada esse tem sido um
grande movimento
não dá pra falar de abundância a gente
não fala da criação de um tecido de
confiança
não dá pra falar de vulnerabilização se
a gente não tá mexendo nos nossos
julgamentos e aí uma das coisas que a
gente faz é muitas vezes poder falar
olha eu tô com julgamentos sobre você
agora você quer escutar porque não
adianta a gente falar que não vai jogar
a gente julga aqui está dentro do dna o
que a gente quer
nessa transformação de oh mossa pins
para o miolo - é que a gente possa
lapida desenvolver essa musculatura
conectiva eu quero saber qual é o
momento em que eu não sou mais uma
máquina julgadora que concorda ou
discorda o tempo todo e que saca com
radar zinho que está aqui quando eu pedi
conexão com o outro
a gente sabe né quando perdeu conexão a
gente sabe quando não tem mais escuta do
outro lado tem uma parede ali cheia de
julgamentos e é essa parede esse muro
que a gente quer atravessar bom senso
nem dizer que a comunicação não violenta
é um dos grandes pilares que que a gente
estuda prática ea gente criou um sistema
chamado o que tá vivo que está vivo é
uma reunião sim mesa só com um círculo
de cadeiras onde as pessoas falam aquilo
que está vivo o nome já diz
ou seja eu posso expressar uma
celebração de alguma coisa que está aqui
pulando e eu posso expressar um luta
mento algo que eu lamento bastante que
também está acontecendo
pode ser inclusive que o revele algo que
está acontecendo entre um outro
integrante da nossa comunidade e aí a
gente abre o que tá vivo por um espaço
restaurativo porque a gente quer
transformar o nosso sistema judiciário o
nosso sistema de justiça como é que a
gente faz
sim tem alguém que fez algo trágico em
alguém que fez algo que sem querer gerou
danos para a outra pessoa é porque a
crença que a gente tem aqui e isso é a
construção do tecido de confiança é que
o outro quer meu bem estar
talvez essa seja uma crença muito
arraigada do almoço sapiens homosapiens
ele tem três crenças centrais que é não
há o suficiente para todos mas é melhor
e você não tem escolha
bom vocês já viram o que aconteceu
comigo inclusive quando eu descobri que
eu tinha escolha né nem pintar o cabelo
mas eu precisava o alvo é muita
libertação
bom então essas três crenças elas vão
levar gente para esse lugar que é de que
o outro então não quer meu bem estar
porque já está competindo pra ter mais
do mesmo ou para ter o que é o
suficiente já que não há o suficiente
para todos
o meu colega é um competidor enquanto
não transformo essas crenças que
fundamentam o paradigma no qual a gente
está colocado hoje e que pra isso a
gente precisa de muito depressivo porque
como é que a gente vai dormir com esse
barulho como é que a gente vai dormir
com um mundo baseado em punição e
recompensa em comando e controle com
hierarquias absolutamente artificiais
como abuso de poder com governos que não
são nada inspiradoras e não nos
representam
bom então isso faz parte tem muito mais
coisa acontecendo lá né
o que é muito importante saber é que
quando a gente escolhe viver um mundo da
não-violência e sou significa que a
gente vai ter muito mais conflito do que
a gente tinha antes
tem gente que chega nulo - e fica
assustado porque fala nossa mas são
muito autêntico saque
esperava que ia chegar num lugar cheio
de harmonia um paraíso idílico e uau é
absolutamente desafiador viver com um
grupo de pessoas que se cuida o tempo
todo cada um
esse compromisso lá eu me cuido e um
projeto no outro a razão do meu mal
estar porque eu sou responsável pelos
meus sentimentos e pelas minhas
necessidades e também por articular os
pedidos não esperando que os outros vão
adivinhar aquilo que eu preciso
então é bem desafiador a gente está
nessa construção tão bem longe ainda do
lugar que a gente gostaria de chegar mas
em vez de ficar reclamando centavo lá no
apartamento e tomando antidepressivo um
vinhozinho ou fazendo compras para me
distrair pra me recompensar essa vida
miserável
a gente resolveu fazer alguma coisa e
tem bastante gente fazendo o mesmo em
vários lugares deste planeta é
absolutamente subversivo
é uma transgressão mas eu tenho vontade
de pavimentação havia talvez eu não viva
esse mundo que eu tanto sonho mas pelo
menos me motiva acordar a cada dia e
perceber que eu tô agindo em coerência
com os meus propósitos e mais gostoso
ainda é fazer isso com um grupo de
pessoas que é a minha rede de apoio e
que está absolutamente engajada no mesmo
sonho
o homo sapiens que somos nós a pensar a
pinça
a gente está dando à luz ao bolo - e
como reza a profecia hope
nós somos o povo que estávamos esperando
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i